hundred weeks what are your guys's
favorite uh moments from the first
hundred
oh the iggy azalea wrath has always been
my favorite
though
that might have been the funniest moment
on cats you know my heart
yeah spit it dog [ __ ] [ __ ] iggy oh no
iggy iggy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you got too many good two weeks
suspension iggy iggy [ __ ] illy whether
the amazon tastes kitty silly billy
popping pillies smoking like a
sweatshirt like this
look at my crack after shock
that's all i got that's all i got
but then right after that was one of the
years ago
uh sketch and that might have been the
hardest years ago i've never last so
hard you know when you sent me the
countdowns nick i could not wait to post
that i laughed
so [ __ ] hard years ago that was years
ago
a spoken word for us now right and
tell us what we're about to hear give us
a free style okay i'm just going to
think it out
freestyle absolutely sit back go ahead
marshall okay
years ago to try to years ago they tried
to
put me in it
this is
did you want to try to read something
from your book yeah okay
oh my god the first comment on that
video
you can't blame him not after what they
tried to do it to him years ago
i hope he's doing well uh i actually
have an update on marshall
oh what happened he passed away i was a
huge huge goal to get him
here for the 100th episode i wanted to
have little brows record a song years
ago on the first but then him walk in
we've been on the phone and stuff and
yeah he said his whole family got
covered and his dad who was elderly
passed away like
two weeks ago well this got sad uh but i
mean
like in loving memory uh he he was like
man i i
i would i'm totally down i've been
watching you guys i'm digging it but i'm
just kind of grieving right now
all right
i've laughed so [ __ ] hard there's
been times where i'm laughing so hard
they're not even a show i just keep
laughing yeah
derek you got any uh favorite memories
from uh your time on the show
yeah that's a good question i liked when
theo thought
that we just let some lady have [ __ ] on
her face
he was like why would you allow that i
was like what do you mean he's like look
at her and i didn't know
come on man and i'm like what dude he's
like dude
we can't have this on the show i'm like
what's wrong with her we look in
dog semen
she goes come on man she got that thick
sweat on her face that thanks
sweat what happened to her
like come on that's a man with thick
nuts
oh yeah and then we zoomed in
and he was right we thought it was
someone's on did we still have that
we still had that video i forgot about
that yeah that one that one [ __ ] that
was fun oh that was amazing
oh i don't remember anything i hope he's
out there
scary we do so many shows you remember
all of it i don't i forgot about that
that was hilarious dude
cause yeah you guys are all like she had
a question you guys were like trying to
answer her questions we were dead
serious
i was like like she like couldn't find a
man i was like this is what you got to
do girl
here we go there we go there's a lot of
stuff going on here she's got that
mascara like your boy said
derek zoom in on that i hold the [ __ ]
dude
there's [ __ ] all over no one's noticed
this
that's semen isn't it
she's not a [ __ ] cinnamon roll is she
that's not icing deal
bro this is a man dude that's not a man
she's making a porno and this was the
end of it
you know what don't cut out the part i
said in the beginning because i was
trying to go back to this
look at the whole thing going on here
the blonde hair doesn't match the rest
of her hair
this is a man's face and he got busted
on he must be off cigarettes
oh god yeah he's flying spirit airlines
he's off secrets
he works at a doll factory this is a
young fella man
this is a nice young man who enjoys
pizza
and getting loads on his face well who
knows
i'm a detective way too much 48. i
hey kay soft you're a detective dude
you're the worst detective you've spent
six minutes praising this young lass
dude what are you talking about he said
a couple nice
tits i talked about taking her out for a
good time the first thing i said was
that this young
fella zoom in
you did call it hey hold on how does no
one
run in the cameras see the [ __ ] semen
on this dude's face
bro what is this turned into man i don't
want to be a part of anything like this
man
yeah let's not well let's put this on
this time but i ain't doing this stuff
where i'm looking at semen on some fella
man
it might be sweat though that ain't
sweat that's thick thick sweat out of
somebody's nuts
it is dude i'm serious man we can do it
this time i'm not looking at this kind
of stuff i didn't come here to look at
this
oh my god then we made six sweatshirts
it went through so many checks though it
went through the nick
everyone no one saw he said you're the
worst detective ever
oh that lady oh i [ __ ] forgot about
that
guy that was a man that was definitely a
man absolutely
forget that if dude dress up like a
woman is a uh is a man a dude
yeah you remember the first episode when
we had chin's aunt on
and i was so crunk for his aunt he's hot
yeah she's batty
wait last episode didn't we talk about
how theo might have hooked up with
theo's i mean chins on because she was
in i don't know
yeah yeah she was a korean it was i just
remember it was a korean lady
and i remember we tried to get involved
and have some sort of sexual interaction
but
she wasn't into it no she was into it
brendan yeah were you not into it huh
that's other friends of yours um
[Laughter]
bro you got the wrong [ __ ] you're
friends too brother
but i met him through you dude okay
i just remember her i will say this
about this korean lady i remember her
legs didn't dv they wouldn't
her her lips open up they were kind of
like you know chopsticks are kind of
like at the top they're kind of just
like that
there was no way to have sex because her
just her leg it was like trying to work
yeah i was like trying to get those
sticks apart and they wouldn't come
apart and you're like oh this doesn't
work so now
you want to tell chin or should i that
you're his uncle
i'd be happy i'll be proud did it be so
awesome if i were if you were oh that'd
be cool
what here it is right here no this was
another one of my uh
favorite moments um these these guys
oh yeah why did we do this it was your
birthday yeah
he just got back from hawaii too so nice
super chat yeah
what was that for you're welcome i don't
know
christmas
yeah those guys were great i was feeling
myself remember i kept clowning them too
yeah when they left i was all mean about
it oh yeah because they went one song
too long
yeah i got old fast yeah i think it's
you do two songs when you're there two
two and out and they
we remember killing them to leave when
you stay for that third song it's rough
do you guys remember when we set up just
know like pictures of you
remember that remember totally went on
the date and drank all that sake and we
paid for it we talked about it every
week i gotta forget about this
yeah jim went on that date with hot carl
and here's how carl now and
you destroyed her life
another great one and i'm almost have
the video up instagram to make me log in
but uh the first time we were introduced
uh to noodling
uh we we met that fellow who wasn't tv
camera ready
oh yeah oh yeah that dude that had his
shirt off all up in the video
yeah saint tricholus this day the body
adios yeah saint tits
yeah and he's all up in the water trying
to catch some fish
oh yeah he'd be under the water come up
really seductively yeah
that brack is saying you got to get in
there
yeah those boys don't want to get caught
let's get a shot of this guy why did he
do
i think his noodling's different than
the rest of people
it's okay the girls come at night after
that old man leaves
oh i'll be back in the morning i had a
good time timmy gonna be back tomorrow
when i leave my shirt and pants and lip
gloss
what's going on in this [ __ ]
father
father tom got them boo radley tips
his tits are water logged huh look at
his whole skin
he exploded and dead what else did we
talk about well you guys brought my dad
on
oh oh yeah we had a family reunion yeah
when
theo asked if he did the crime that's
right
yeah he was a good yeah he said look
what did he say he had to get he said he
goes put it this way
i studied law and got myself out
only person whose family has not been
represented is chappelle's
we tried to reach out to your dad to get
a video but we just couldn't get one i'm
sorry
it's okay oh okay crying but don't be
sad man we got
a surprise that's what happens sometimes
chappelle we love you we got a special
in-studio guest
oh yeah oh gee triple oh yeah
and did you do it whatever you went to
prison for
legit questions well i mean
yeah that's a that's a hell of a
question
hey man dude we should have made some
free uh your dad's name t-shirts
oh my god oh we should have free kevin
free kevin yeah
his name is big kev
what's up barcelona oh wow what's his
real name though
kevin oh big kev yep free bossolini
black that would have been dope if we
made this [ __ ]
no a lot of people may be confused at
what we're talking about because that
was uh the family reunion uh
patreon episode uh yeah so so that's
still available there
we also got cats after dark on there too
a lot yeah
[Music]
is